[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend den allen die Haltbarkeit
politischer Aussagen ist gerade
umgekehrt proportional zur Dramatik der
Lage die gasumlage steht vor dem Aus
obwohl sie laut Regierung Wichtiges
stabilitätsinstrument für den deutschen
Gasmarkt werden sollte sie steht vor dem
Aus obwohl sie noch nicht mal in Kraft
ist das heißt um die Verwirrung komplett
zu machen sie könnte Ende der Woche
tatsächlich mal kurz in Kraft treten
aber ohne dass sie jemanden zahlen soll
jedenfalls sagt der Grünen Chef jetzt
auf die Frage wann genau das Vorhaben
aus dem Haus des grünen
Wirtschaftsministers denn nun gekippt
wird so schnell es irgendwie nur geht
und wie verfranzt die Lage am
politischen Energiemarkt ist zeigt auch
der Satz eines Regierungssprechers heute
er verspricht die Struktur einer
Gesamtlösung werde sehr schnell sichtbar
in einem geordneten Verfahren Karl
Hinterleitner
die Verwirrung bleibt die gasumlage wird
zum Stresstest für die Koalition dass
sie misslungen ist das bestehen
mittlerweile sogar mehr oder weniger die
Regierungsparteien selbst ein wichtig
ist dass die Bundesregierung gezeigt hat
dass sie in der Lage ist einen Fehler
auch zu erkennen und dann als solchen am
Ende auch zu korrigieren das passiert
jetzt gerade in diesen Tagen vor allem
den Importeur Juniper hatte die
gasumlage retten sollen durch die
Verstaatlichung der Firma entfällt
dieser Grund wie die Regierung
stattdessen Industrie und Verbraucher
entlasten kann darüber gibt es Streit
vor allem zwischen FDP und Grünen
zwischen dem Finanz und dem
Wirtschaftsminister ich kann versichern
dass Robert Habeck alles dafür tut damit
die Umlage so schnell wie möglich fällt
aber alle Nachfolgemodelle die man sich
vorstellen kann kosten Geld und das Geld
muss der Finanzminister natürlich dann
Bereitstellen von einer gaspreisbremse
hatte Christian Lindner gesprochen doch
wie die genau aussehen kann wann sie
kommt und wie man sie bezahlen soll sagt
er bis jetzt nicht
ich möchte mit ihnen nicht über
Instrumente spekulieren verstehe Ihre
Neugier aber ich halte daran fest dass
ich öffentlich nicht einzelne
Instrumente nenne
sondern Ihnen dann das präsentiere auf
was wir uns innerhalb der
Bundesregierung verständigt haben
verbraucherschütze kritisieren die
Regierung die unklare Kommunikation
lasse die Gaskunden ratlos zurück ein
hin und herein die Kartoffeln raus aus
den Kartoffeln das trägt zu
Verunsicherung leider weiter bei was die
Bundesregierung dort gerade diskutiert
und was sie veranstaltet insofern wäre
es jetzt wichtig Dinge schnell zu
beschließen auch die Opposition drängt
jetzt fünf Tage bevor die gasumlage
kommen sollte müsse die Regierung eine
Alternative präsentieren
wenn Lindner sagt der soll eine
Preisbremse kommen da ist es gut aber
die brauchen wir jetzt er muss jetzt
Vorschläge machen er muss jetzt
vortragen was das kosten würde wie es ja
nach seiner Auffassung tatsächlich auch
in Einklang steht mit der Schuldenbremse
da ist die Regierung jetzt am Zug und
der Tränen wir auf Taten doch eine
schnelle Einigung scheint schwierig denn
der
FDP-Fraktionsvorsitzende legt heute noch
eine Forderung drauf wir sind bereit
eine gaspreisbremse einzuführen
umgekehrt erwarte ich jetzt von den
Grünen dass sie auch eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
zustimmen
eine Antwort darauf gab es bisher nicht
sicher scheint nur eins die gasumlage
ist tot viel Streit und noch keine
Lösung in Sicht
ja klare Linie whatever it takes you'll
never walk alone von den eigenen
Vorgaben der Regierung ist das
Krisenmanagement derselben Regierung ja
ganz offensichtlich weit entfernt guten
Abend Theo kann man das noch mal
nachzeichnen wie diese gasumlage von
einer regierungsidee zum rohrkrippierer
wurde
also der Weg zum rohrkrippierer war kurz
aber ich glaube ziemlich schmerzhaft und
ein Beleg dafür wie wenig offensichtlich
unser
Regierungsapparat auf eine so
Unvertraute Krise
reaktionsfähig ist die Ursprungsidee war
ja mit der Umlage diejenigen Firmen zu
retten die bisher in ganz großem Stil
russisches Gas eingekauft hatten und
damit beispielsweise die Stadtwerke und
damit ja uns Endverbraucher versorgt
haben diese Firmen wie uniper mussten
nach dem russischen Lieferstopp
plötzlich ja zur absoluten Mondpreisen
auf dem Weltmarkt Einkaufen das aber
konnten sie da nicht an die Kunden
weitergeben die Umlage der
Gasverbraucher sollte diese Lücke
überbrücken helfen dann aber passierte
fehler Nummer eins stellte man fest dass
auf die Umlage auch Mehrwertsteuer
bezahlt werden müsste der Staat also
auch noch dran verdient fehler Nummer
zwei war dann das ist doch tatsächlich
in der Wirtschaft so etwas wie
Trittbrettfahrer geben soll also Firmen
die die Umlage zwar nicht brauchen aber
trotzdem die Hand aufgehalten hätten und
der letzte Sargnagel war dann das uniper
und andere nur noch durch komplett
Verstaatlichung zu retten waren und
damit wäre die Umlage dann in einer Art
Steuer verwandelt worden in der Summe
gilt eine Umlage drei Fehler
ein Wahnsinn und dann gucken wir mal
nach vorne Theo wie soll es denn jetzt
konkret weitergehen was ist denn konkret
zu erwarten
nun zu erwarten ist eigentlich dass in
dieser Woche eigentlich sofort die
politischen Spitzen der Ampel verhandeln
und entscheiden wie sie diese Untote
namensumlage beerdigen und wie Sie sie
dann ersetzen wobei der Kanzler ja nur
virtuell mitverhandeln kann da sich
Corona eingefangen hat und abgeschottet
in seiner Wohnung im Kanzleramt sitzt es
dürfte am Ende auf eine Gaspreis Bremse
hinauslaufen wie sie auch andere Länder
schon haben die große Frage ist aber
dann natürlich die der Finanzierung also
sei es über ein sogenanntes
Sondervermögen wir kennen das als
Schattenhaushalt bei den militärmeladen
oder aber durch direkte Schulden im
Haushalt das aber will der
Finanzminister Lindner nicht weil er
sich weiter versucht eine Schuldenbremse
festzuhalten ganz entspannt wir haben
noch immer vier bis fünf Tage bis über
30 Millionen Gaskunden wissen sollten ob
die gasumlage kommt oder doch nicht ja
bleibt dann das Lachen fast im Halse
stecken herzlichen Dank Theo wird auf
jeden Fall eine spannende Woche in
Berlin und nicht nur hier bei uns in
Deutschland wird sie spannend Italien
ist bunt und quirlig und ein bisschen
verrückt so könnte man auch seine
Politik beschreiben und dabei wie beim
Rest des Landes ins Schwärmen geraten
aber so einfach ist es halt dann doch
nicht Italien hat gewählt wieder einmal
das Land bekommt im Schnitt alle 14
Monate eine neue Regierung aber dieses
Wahlergebnis hat es in sich und war so
noch nie da Meloni nimmt sich Italien
schreibt eine Tageszeitung heute über
die große Siegerin Georgia miloni wird
wohl die erste
Ministerpräsidentin Italiens werden und
die erste aus einer Partei in der viele
den Völkermörder und Diktator Mussolini
als Helden verehren Annette hilsenbeck
ist in Rom
das Leben läuft wie immer auf den
Straßen Roms in den Trattorien zur
Mittagszeit doch heute gibt es ein Thema
das viele Gespräche dominiert Italien
hat gewählt und wird eine rechte
Regierung bekommen
ich hoffe auf einen großen Wandel ich
hoffe dass ich die Dinge ändern werden
insbesondere für solche Menschen mit
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen
sie haben viele Versprechungen gemacht
jetzt ist es wichtig die zu halten denn
wer erwarten eine bessere Regierung
ich habe aufgehört darüber nachzudenken
ich akzeptiere was kommt es ändert sich
ja doch nichts
sie steht schon in der Nacht als
Siegerin fest Georgia melloni holte mit
ihrer rechtsradikalen fratelli die
Thalia die stärkste Partei geworden ist
über 26 Prozent Meloni wird wohl
Ministerpräsidentin und gibt sich
bereits staatstragend
wenn wir ein Teil der Geschichte werden
wollen müssen wir verstehen dass wir
eine Verantwortung haben gegenüber
Millionen von Menschen denn Italien hat
uns gewählt und wir werden sie nicht
betrügen
es ist ein Rechtsruck melonis fratelli
d'Italia gilt als nationalkonservativ
mit faschistischen Wurzeln mit ihren
Bündnispartnern expremier Berlusconi mit
seiner rechtskonservativen Forza Italia
um Matteo salvinis rechtspopulistischer
leger hat sie eine klare Mehrheit
zunächst einmal glaube ich dass die
Italiener eine Anti ist der
brisment-stimme abgeben wollten und der
Großteil derer die für Georgia Meloni
gestimmt haben stellt nicht allzu viele
Fragen darüber wofür Georgia Meloni
steht
die sozialdemokratische PD wurde
zweitstärkste Partei hatte es aber vor
der Wahl nicht geschafft eine große
Mitte links-allianz zu schmieden
wir werden jetzt in die Opposition gehen
mit großer Entschlossenheit
ich werde nicht mehr kandidieren denn es
ist Aufgabe einer neuen Generation die
PD zu erneuern für Italien
die Wahlbeteiligung war mit 63,9 Prozent
historisch niedrig mehr als ein Drittel
der italienischen Wahlberechtigten ist
gar nicht zur Urne gegangen das
Vertrauen der Italiener in die Politik
hat noch mehr abgenommen
und Europa ist selbst gespalten aus
Ungarn und Polen kommen Glückwünsche in
Brüssel ahnen sie dass es mit Meloni
noch mal deutlich schwieriger werden
dürfte als ohnehin schon andererseits
gilt gerade bei diesem Gründungsmitglied
der EU das unter enormen Schulden echt
europa braucht Italien aber Italien
braucht auch Europa Florian
[Musik]
allein schon die Musik ist so kitschig
dass es der letzte versteht da kommen
Freunde hier Silvio Berlusconi der eine
ultra-rechte zur Ministerpräsidentin
machen will dort Manfred Weber Chef der
Europäischen Volkspartei csuvize eine
Wahlempfehlung
die anderswo für Unverständnis sorgt
auch noch am Tag nach der Wahl
München csu-vorstandssitzung der
CSU-Vorsitzenden nutzt die Gelegenheit
seinem Vize eins auszuwischen wir haben
immer klargemacht dass wir eine
Brandmauer zur rechtsradikalen
neofaschistischen Gruppen ziehen es ist
nicht Aufgabe der EVP und bürgerlicher
Parteien
rechtsnationale und rechtsradikaler
Regierungen zu ermöglichen
Berlusconis Forza Italia ist mit ihren 8
Prozent was man Steigbügelhalter nennen
könnte für Georgia Meloni die heute
viele Glückwünsche erreichen geografisch
aus ganz Europa politisch aus einer
Richtung Rechtsaußen gratulation
schreibt der polnische premier als einer
der ersten Bravo Georgia freut sich der
ungarische Ministerpräsident Viktor
Orban und mit Ausrufezeichen jubelt auch
die AFD die Politik die man bisher
betrieben haben die die Europäische
Union vorangetrieben hat Migration
dieses Woche denken die sie ihre
Außenpolitik
das möchte der Wähler nicht mehr haben
was mindestens Ansichtssache ist und
viele andere Wähler wie Politiker in
Europa verschreckt die Aussicht dass die
innereuropäische Opposition gegen
Brüssel gegen die Durchsetzung des
Rechtsstaats gegen Russland Sanktionen
künftig womöglich stärker wird
Orban wird in Italien in Georgia Meloni
eine starke Verbündete haben es ist kein
Zufall dass er schon als einer der
ersten gratuliert hat Meloni hat gesagt
Orban ist ihr Vorbild das wird ein
großes Problem werden für Europa von
Problemen will man bei der EU-Kommission
öffentlich nicht reden gibt sich betont
gelassen als wäre eine rechte Regierung
in einem Gründungsmitglied ganz
gewöhnlich
die Europäische Kommission und ihre
Präsidentin arbeiten mit den Regierungen
zusammen die aus den Wahlen in den
europäischen Staaten hervorgehen
Selektion
Europäern und Manfred Weber ist heute
den Tag über abgetaucht will sich am
Abend dann doch äußern er stehe zu der
Wahlwerbung
der Journalist Paolo berezi von der
italienischen Tageszeitung la Republica
muss seit dreieinhalb Jahren unter
Polizeischutz leben rund um die Uhr weil
er Morddrohungen bekommt von Neo
faschistischen Gruppen über die er
schreibt
das sage ich jetzt hier mal eben so aber
allein das ist ja mitten in Europa
bereits ein unfassbarer Zustand guten
Abend
Grazie guten Abend und vielen Dank für
die Einladung was erwarten sie denn
jetzt nach dem Wahlsieg der extremen
Rechten in Italien für ihren Alltag
nun wenn die Signale so sind wie wir sie
heute vernommen haben
dann ist es so dass viele von denen die
mich täglich
bedrohen
sich jetzt beschützt fühlen und bestärkt
fühlen auf eine gewisse Weise also sie
haben schon damit begonnen daraus die
Konsequenzen zu ziehen und sie haben
schon
Dinge gesagt wie also hau ab oder bring
dich um oder du wirst sowieso hier
vertrieben solche Reaktionen gab es
bereits und das überrascht mich in
keinster Weise nur ist es so dass wenn
die Führung in Italien einfach so
darüber hinweggeht und einen
Journalisten nicht schützt der so
bedroht wird von den militanten Personen
dann ist das sehr schlecht denn sie sind
ja sehr stark vernetzt und sie sind
nicht zart beseitet sie bedrohen mich
und irgendwann wird es vielleicht auch
weitergehen aber ich mache mit meiner
Arbeit weiter ich mache einfach immer
weiter und versuche den Angriffen und
Attacken so gut wie möglich
entgegenzutreten
jetzt war das eine demokratische Wahl
aber an deren Ende muss man fragen wie
gefährlich sind die Wahlgewinner für die
Demokratie was meinen Sie
also ich bin hier sehr klar ich glaube
nicht dass mit Georgia Meloni und den
fratellititalia an der Regierung direkt
der Faschismus zurückkehrt das glaube
ich nicht jedenfalls nicht so wie wir
ihn aus der Geschichte kennen
die wirkliche Gefahr besteht darin dass
unsere Demokratie geschwächt wird sie
wird angegriffen und das steht schon im
Grunde im Wahlprogramm der fratelli
Italia wo es heißt dass man die
Verfassung möglicherweise verändern will
Verfassung unserer Republik das ist ja
doch die Grundlage unserer Demokratie
und da wollen die dran gehen also die
wirkliche Gefahr für unsere Demokratie
besteht darin dass man so ganz leise in
etwas anderes abgeleitet eine Situation
abgeleitet wo wir keine wirkliche
Demokratie mehr haben sondern ein
autoritäres Regime wir haben das schon
in Ungarn mit Urban gesehen und
beobachtet und
Company ist steht ihr mir sehr positiv
gegenüber das ist das wahre Risiko
haben sie gesagt es besteht die Gefahr
dass Italien langsam abgeleitet was
glauben Sie was ihre Landsleute dazu
sagen ist ihnen das egal setzen sie
gerade zu da drauf also vor allem die
Wähler natürlich von Georgia Meloni und
ihren fratelli d'Italia oder haben sie
das einfach im Moment immer noch nicht
als als Bedrohung tatsächlich vor sich
welches
es wurde sehr stark unterschätzt und
zwar jahrelang es wurde auch banalisiert
das Phänomen wurde nicht so erkannt wie
es wirklich ist ich glaube dass die
Wähler der fratelli d'Italia sich in
zwei verschiedene Kategorien unterteilen
lassen es gibt einen Teil der wieder
schafft er sich ja moderat ist und dann
gibt es einen Teil der Wählerschaft der
sicherlich
das braucht dass diese Symbole
existieren dieses Logans die werden
wirklich gesucht auch von dieser
Wählerschaft und ein roter Faden wird
gesucht etwas an dem man sich
orientieren kann und das geht in die
Richtung des Faschismus also wenn man
auch Italien
nicht so in der Gefahr sieht dass wir
auch keinen wirklichen Neofaschismus
erwarten können so gehen wir doch in die
Richtung und die Partei mit der wir es
zu tun haben steht auf jeden Fall in der
Tradition in der Faschisten die fratelli
d'Italia ist Faschisten die sind da
tatsächlich drin und wir können im
Grunde sagen dass seit 45 bis heute ist
die Regierung ist die so rechts ist wie
keine andere Regierung in der
Zwischenzeit ist war es ist ganz klar
dass die Faschisten im Grunde doch
irgendwo Anteil an der Regierung
Italiens haben das ist eine Tatsache
sie als Touristen da kennen wir Italien
als Traumland als Sehnsuchtsland wie
würden Sie uns denn ihr Land beschreiben
und vor allem seinen aktuellen Zustand
bei dem ja viele Italienerinnen
Italiener offensichtlich gar nicht mehr
zur Wahl gehen und dann sehr viele den
extremen rechten Rand wählen
in wenigen Tagen jetzt zum hundertsten
Mal der Marsch auf Rom am 20 Oktober das
war der Anfangspunkt des früheren
Faschismus und Italien
hat heute
festgestellt und gemerkt das ist eine
Regierung haben wird mit Faschisten und
dieser Marsch auf Rom der Anfang des
Faschismus das ist sicherlich ein
bedeutendes Datum das uns noch mal zum
nachdenken bringen sollte mit was wir es
hier zu tun haben und
manches was wir da sehen hat wenig zu
tun mit Demokratie und es geht sich an
eine andere Richtung das wird langsam
passieren aber es wird doch passieren
aber wenn wir wirklich wach geworden
sind dann können wir vielleicht noch was
tun
von La Republica herberitzi hat sich
dank für das Gespräch heute abend Graz
muss Gespräche aus technischen Gründen
vor einer Stunde aufgezeichnet der
italienische Kollege wird wohl weiter
polizei-schutz brauchen
weitere wichtige Nachrichten jetzt von
diesem Montag im Überblick den hast du
Hanna seit Tagen gehen iranische
Sicherheitskräfte gewaltsam gegen die
regimekritischen Proteste im Land vor
nun tatsächlich bundesaußenministerin
baerbock für neue EU-Sanktionen gegen
Iran ausgesprochen zudem hat das
Auswärtige Amt den iranischen
Botschafter einbestellt 41 Menschen
sollen laut offiziellen Angaben bisher
getötet worden sein Grund für die
Proteste ist der Tod der 22-jährigen
machsa Amini sie war im Polizeigewahrsam
gestorben nachdem sie wegen eines
Verstoßes gegen die Kleiderordnung
festgenommen worden war
in Fulda hat heute die viertägige
Herbstvollversammlung der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz begonnen und ein
großes Thema dabei sind die Reformen in
der Kirche und die Uneinigkeit darüber
unter den Bischöfen konkret geht es auch
um ein Grundsatzpapier zur kirchlichen
Sexualmoral das Anfang September bei der
synodalversammlung an den Nein stimmen
konservativer Bischöfe gescheitert war
ein weiterer Punkt auf der Tagesordnung
ist die Suche nach einem neuen
Missbrauchsbeauftragten
einen Tag nach erneuten Raketentests
durch Nordkorea haben die USA und
Südkorea ein gemeinsames marinemanöver
vor der koreanischen Halbinsel begonnen
ziel ist unter anderem die Abschreckung
Nordkoreas an der viertägigen Übung
nehmen laut der südkoreanischen Marine
mehr als 20 Kriegsschiffe teil darunter
auch der US Flugzeugträger Ronald Reagan
die Spannungen in der Region haben sich
verschärft da Pjöngjang seit
Jahresbeginn zahlreiche Raketentests
durchgeführt hat
in der Stadt Ischewsk in Zentral
russland hat ein Mann in einer Schule
mindestens 15 Menschen erschossen und
sich danach selbst getötet unter den
Todesopfern sollen elf Kinder sein
mindestens 24 Personen wurden verletzt
laut Behörden soll der Täter einen
Oberteil mit Hakenkreuz getragen haben
und früher selbst Schüler an der Schule
gewesen sein grammelsprecher peskov
sprach von einem terroristischen Akt
und wir bleiben noch bei dem was gerade
in Russland passiert was hier aussieht
wie Ferienende in den Bergen ist ein
gewaltiger Exodus eine Kilometer lange
Fluchtbewegung von Russen vor der
Einberufung in die Armee das ist die
Grenze nach Georgien bis zu 48 Stunden
im Stau ähnliche Bilder auch an anderen
Grenzen und dazu im Land Proteste die
wütender werden immer neue Fälle von
Bränden in
militärkommissariaten seit der
Teilmobilmachung beginnt es zu gären im
Riesenreich des Wladimir Putin mehr
jetzt von Nina Niebergall
sogar in Russlands kremlt royster
Talkshow verhehlen sie nicht ihre
Verachtung für das was da gerade im Land
passiert dass Männer rekrutiert werden
die offiziell noch gar nicht an die
frontsäulen ausgerechnet von der
Chefredakteurin von Putins Propaganda
wir alle haben gelesen dass die erste
Welle aus Soldaten und Offizieren bis 35
bestehen würde aber muss ich wirklich
sagen wie viele Einberufungen ein
45-jähriger verschickt wurden ich glaube
sogar ein 62-jähriger hat es geschafft
ich habe einen 59-Jährigen gesehen
letztendlich muss dagegen etwas gemacht
werden könnten wir die Verantwortlichen
erschießen
ich bin gegen das Erschießen von
Menschen ich bin dafür in der
Öffentlichkeit
polemische dahergesagte Worte doch heute
kommen sie der Realität in Russland
gefährlich nah in Ostsibirien schießt
ein Mann offenbar Reservist auf den
Leiter der einberufungsstelle dieser
wird schwer verletzt
in der Nähe von Moskau zündet sich ein
Reservist selbst an aus Protest so sagt
er hier wird er abgeführt
seit der Teil Mobilmachung nehmen auch
solche Angriffe auf einberufungsstellen
zu die Täter kommen aus allen
politischen Richtungen
im ganzen Land wächst der Widerstand
kein Krieg kein Krieg rufen diese Frauen
in Dagestan im Süden Russlands warum
holt ihr unsere Männer und Kinder Weg
fragen Sie diesen Polizisten
ausgerechnet hier einem der ärmsten
Teile des Landes wo sie schon viele
Söhne Väter Ehemänner an die Front
verloren haben die Staatsmacht reagiert
mit über 100 Festnahmen
weil sich Meldungen häufen dass Männer
eingezogen wurden die zu alt sind oder
Väter vieler Kinder räumt selbst der
Kreml heute ein
diese Fälle wo die erforderlichen
Kriterien nicht erfüllt sind werden
korrigiert wir hoffen dass die
Geschwindigkeit dieser Korrekturen
steigen wird dass alle Fehler korrigiert
werden
doch immer weniger Russen so scheint es
Vertrauen den Verantwortlichen tausende
verlassen das Land wie hier über die
georgische Grenze in Sicherheit finden
sie überraschend deutliche Worte
wie viele andere befürchten wir dass sie
uns gegen unseren Willen einziehen
könnten um friedliche Menschen in einem
anderen Land in der Ukraine zu töten wir
sind absolut gegen diesen Krieg und wir
nennen ihn so wie er ist es ist keine
Operation es ist ein Krieg den Russland
auf dem Territorium der Ukraine führt
am Abend wird die Grenze nach Georgien
sogar für Fußgänger geöffnet es ist die
stillste Form des Widerstands aber für
Putins Regime wohl die schmerzhafteste
morgen sollen die
pseudovolksabstimmungen in den von
Russland besetzten Gebieten in der
Ukraine abgeschlossen sein es halten
sich Gerüchte dass Russland dann auch
seine Grenzen dicht machen werde
zumindest für Männer
noch mal Hannah jetzt hier bei uns ja
und zwar mit Wirtschaft und da haben
heute Begriffe wie Präzession und
Pessimismus die Schlagzeilen bestimmt
der
ifo-Geschäftsklimaindex ist auf den
tiefsten Stand seit Mai 2020 gerutscht
die Stimmung in der deutschen Wirtschaft
hat sich im September stärker
verschlechtert als erwartet und Valerie
Haller in Frankfurt dieser düstere Blick
auf die kommenden Monate der zieht sich
so ziemlich durch alle Branchen oder ja
genau querbeet besonders pessimistisch
aber ist wohl der Einzelhandel dass die
Geschäftserwartungen so schlecht wie nie
zuvor gemäß ifo Umfrage plant auch mehr
als jedes zweite Unternehmen
Preiserhöhungen wegen der gestiegenen
Kosten die Wirtschaft belasten viele
Faktoren gleichzeitig der Ukraine Krieg
die Energiekrise Lieferprobleme
Welthandel und steigende Zinsen die
Kredite verteuern und Investitionen
bremsen die Folgen der teuren Energie
sind weitreichend und vor allem
verstärken sie einander wegen sehr hohen
Gaspreise werden Produktionen unrentabel
und erste Unternehmen stellen schon
vorübergehend den Betrieb ein deren
Produkte fehlen womöglich anderen Firmen
verbraucher können sich weniger leisten
und schränken den Konsum ein dabei hat
die Inflation ihren Höhepunkt vermutlich
noch gar nicht erreicht kaum ein Ökonom
der nicht mit einer Rezession rechnet
der schwache Ifo-Index ein neuerlicher
haberrückschlag für die Konjunktur wir
stehen vor einem wirtschaftlich
schwierigen Winter ein dickes Minus auf
allen Fronten der ifoindex ist
Deutschlands wichtigster konjunktureller
früh Indikator dass er so stark gefallen
ist zeigt einmal mehr dass vielleicht
schon im Winter eine Rezession droht
gute Nachricht der Arbeitsmarkt dürfte
weitgehend stabil bleiben die
Unternehmen gaben an ihre Mitarbeiter so
weit wie möglich halten zu wollen
danke Valerie nach Frankfurt
über die Kanarischen Inseln ist ein
Tropensturm hinweggefegt und hat den
Flugverkehr stark beeinträchtigt mehrere
hundert Flüge mussten gestrichen werden
viele Passagiere saßen auch heute noch
an den Flughäfen der Inselfest
truppensturm Hermine brachte vor allem
heftige Regenfälle die von anhaltender
Dürre versiegelten Böden konnten die
Wassermengen nicht aufnehmen es kam zu
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutschen Tote
und Verletzte soll es nicht gegeben
haben
deutlich heftiger hat es die Philippinen
getroffen schwere Verwüstungen und
mindestens sechs Tote das ist die
vorläufige Bilanz die super Taifun nouru
dort hinterlassen hat die Böden
erreichten Spitzengeschwindigkeiten von
bis zu 240 Kilometer pro Stunde
Tausender Einwohner des
südostasiatischen Inselstaats waren
vorsorglich in Sicherheit gebracht
worden Präsident Markus Junior machte
sich per Hubschrauber ein Bild von den
Überflutungen
und das war unsere Welt an diesem Montag
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse und unser
heute schon mal Update gibt es heute
gegen
0 Instituts Clemens Fuß zu gastumlage
von uns allen hier im heute schon mal
Team ein angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird ganz typisches
Herbstwetter geben in dieser Woche und
das liegt an einigen Thies die davon
Nordwesten Regen aber auch kühle Luft
heranbringen und kaum ist das eine tief
abgezogen zieht hier von Isa das nächste
hinterher heute Nacht also fällt häufig
Regen und nur zwischen der Ostseeküste
und dem Erzgebirge an der Donau bleibt
es trocken über den Schwarzwald pfeift
richtig stürmischer Südwestwind die
Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 5 Grad
und an diesen Werten ändert sich morgen
über Tag nur wenig die milderen
Temperaturen von 14 Grad gibt es hier im
Osten oder auch am Oberrhein sonst
liegen die Werte bei 8 bis 13 Grad das
wird ein düsterer Dienstag häufig mit
Regen es kann auch mal länger regnen und
an der Nordseeküste entwickeln sich
vielleicht sogar einzelne Gewitter am
Alpenrand sinkt die Schneefallgrenze
etwa oberhalb von 1500 Metern kann es
dann auch schneiden Sonne werden Sie
kaum mal zu Gesicht bekommen das ändert
sich auch am Mittwoch nur wenig am
Donnerstag geht es etwas mehr Sonne und
am Freitag steigen die Temperaturen auf
immerhin 11 bis 18 Grad und jetzt weiten
wir den Blick schauen von Mitteleuropa
in Richtung Asien es hat sich nämlich
ein super Typhoon entwickelt der Taifun
nouru sie sehen hier dass er inzwischen
schon die Philippinen überquert hat er
hatte Kategorie 5 hier sehen sie ganz
gut das Auge über dem Südchinesischen
Meer wird er sich nach einer
vorübergehenden Abschwächung wieder
verstärken und wir erwarten ihn
übermorgen bereits an der Ostküste
Vietnams das behalten wir im Auge guten
Abend